c'est la fin d'un long cauchemar qui a
duré plus de trente ans pour gwyneth man
who is the world is alive
we found love son fils german man
n'avais que 21 mois lorsque son père ali
nooman junior l'a enlevée en 1987 à
toronto
c'est le 25 octobre dernier que lynette
reçoit l'appel téléphonique qu'elle
attendait depuis 31 ans
deux jours plus tard elle rejoint
bouleversé je les sers est très fort je
voulais le toucher m'assurer qu'il était
bien réel il m'a dit maman tu à mes yeux
on s'est serré très fort pendant de
longues minutes le père de son fils
maintenant âgé de 66 ans a réussi à
obtenir de faux papiers d'identité pour
lui et son fils y vivaient dans la ville
devint un homme ou connecticut
il est présentement détenu aux états
unis et fera face à la justice
américaine pour avoir menti aux
autorités canadiennes pour enlèvement
d'enfants et ouais ça c'est triste ce
qu'il a fait un enfant ne devrait jamais
jamais être enlevée de ses parents on
doit leur donner la chance de prendre
leurs propres décisions
les autorités américains de la
gendarmerie royale du canada et la
police de toronto ont travaillé ensemble
pour résoudre cette affaire
german étaient absents aujourd'hui il a
préféré que ça fausse identité il ne
soit pas dévoilée par la police si cette
histoire a connu une fin heureuse
il ya quand même des centaines d'enfants
aux pays qui sont toujours portées
disparues le prof je suis la preuve
qu'il ne faut jamais baisser les bras
j'ai souffert pendant 31 ans
soyez patient fort il n'arrêtait jamais
de croire que tout est possible ici
marie michel lauzon radio canada à
toronto